it's great to be talking today with an
old friend of the show jessie agroed
reich the ceo of splinterlands uh jesse
so great to see you again yeah it's good
to be back how have you been i've been
good uh you know i'm so glad to have
this opportunity to talk to you because
splinterlands is a game that is jumping
right in to the crypto blockchain nft
space and there's there's people in my
audience for whom these terms are just
toxic
and as soon as they hear crypto
blockchain nft they say some combination
of bad for the environment
um scam
illegal sometimes bad for gaming you
know any combination of things and i
want to kind of talk through all of this
so like let's start very top level
you're doing a game
why is nft why why is this even
interesting to you as as someone who's
developing a game
so um
it's a super high level like i i went
back years ago and looked at this planet
and i said
uh there's a lot of a lot of things that
are wrong and and frankly it was my mom
that gave me operating instructions of
leave this world a better place than the
one that you found it so when i went
looking for the things that were wrong i
thought that there was
too much poverty too much war
and and the surveillance state was not a
comforting thing to me and when i
started looking for antidotes to that i
found peace prosperity and freedom and
when i went for looking for tools i
found that uh cryptocurrency was really
the best tool out there to facilitate
trade to make good relations to protect
freedom of speech to
just there's so many benefits that come
with this kind of like personal
ownership and so i wanted peace
prosperity and freedom the the single
best highway for that felt like uh or
the best tool for that was crypto and to
really get people into that it wasn't
going to be trading or something it was
really just going to be like it had to
be gaming it had to be something
concrete so
we went into gaming and
because we wanted people to experience
all these benefits and i and i hear the
concerns of like man i i've definitely
you go on twitter for any number of
minutes and you you hear outrage for any
given number of reasons but you know i i
can understand at a high level why why
some people get nervous about these
things but when i look at it these are
the single best tools in anybody's
toolbox to make positive change and
that's part of why i spend all my time
and life trying to to bring people into
this universe it's not to you know like
web 2.0 is so extractive from a human
you know like you play a video game and
web 2.0 free to play or something and
you know they measure it and how many
hours do you spend playing and they
measure it and how many how much money
have they extracted from you and like
that to me feels so creepy like i i want
i want my audience to be thinking about
like well how much i every day i wake up
and i think how can i put more value
into our community how do i how do i
bring more value to the community
members and that's typically either
through the game mechanics through our
community through the economy in the
game how do i benefit them and and that
is not a web 2.0 conversation and
honestly people shouldn't be afraid of
that conversation they should be excited
for that conversation so let's talk
about some of some of the pieces then i
mean uh just to pick something right one
of the one of the emails i got
not that long ago is
um the use of nfts in games is
fundamentally
predatory it's the worst of vulture
capitalism and it's essentially
uh
using the people that are already
customers of the game to extract further
value out of them and it's predatory and
that that those are the dynamics of
introducing nfts into games what do you
say so i i think that they're so nfts
are a tool and like any other tool you
can use that tool for good and you can
use that tool for bad so i don't want to
come out here and blanket your audience
with just like nfqs are good shut up and
swallow this no no you guys should be
skeptical of anything that's out there
and ask yourself is this benefiting us
or hurting us so nfts can be extractive
they can be this kind of like you know
money grab situation where they're
taking money from the audience and like
two months later they're valueless but
the the
person that promoted it is basically a
scammer or just out there for a quick
buck and that is pretty um it is a way
in which they have scalped value out of
the people that are participating
on the flip side when you have a health
a healthy project those nfts basically
allow you to have ownership of some
piece of the success of that project so
instead of instead of just being like
i'm going to extract value from that
person it is now like
we are on the same journey together and
we are trying to go build this this game
this community this economy and we are
working together as partners in that uh
because you you own digital assets in it
so i you know i think it really comes
down to
is there utility is there a real
community is there a project is it a
game is it is it something that provides
value which could be social which could
be a lot of different things but you
know is there is there a project that's
actually there and if the answer is yes
and and it's designed smartly these
things can be so freaking empowering but
i i want to give i want to give your
audience the fair shake that if people
are using these to extract value they
absolutely can so it's a tool and let's
let's be cognizant of there can be
benefits and problems associated with
any tool and let's make sure that if
you're participating in something it's
not just there to extract value out of
you it sort of reminds me of some of the
conversations at the start of
technologies we that are totally
ubiquitous now
like email for example or high-speed
file sharing of all kinds or you know
earlier internet technologies where
there were these discussions about like
well
this is potentially good but here's a
lot of the things that could be really
bad about that and what a lot of kind of
internet technology theologians have
have come to conclude is
um
whenever you introduce a new tool or
mechanism
it's essentially impossible to have only
the good be what comes from it and that
the the things that are enabled by the
tool are going to take place and it's a
question of how to kind of keep them in
balance and put in the right regulatory
oversight or whatever the case may be
the conversation seems very similar
where like these technologies lend
themselves to good and bad and it's it's
implementation and regulation it seems i
i think it's even older than that you
know i i think you know my background
that i'm a former professor yeah and and
one of my teaching colleagues showed me
a picture
of somebody complaining about a literal
chalkboard being introduced into the
classroom and how that chalkboard
technology was going to ruin the way
that that students learn you know this
this is as old as time that when you
introduce new things you know there's a
contingent that can only see the bad
that can't that can't recognize the the
things that might be empowering from
that technology from the other side
sometimes people have a vested interest
in the way that they operate today and
so that that opposition might even be
astroturf so you know
i i look to the source of where that's
coming from and it you know look that
there are some bad things that happen
with nft pro like nft projects that
there can be scams that there can be rug
pulls and so i i don't want to come out
here and say just every nft is good but
you know new technologies bring with
them new new aspects that we need to
consider and
uh programmable assets that's what these
are you know your nft is a digital deed
and that digital deed can be programmed
to do things that is one of the most
powerful conceptual advances in
ownership technology that this world has
ever seen so
um there will be good with that there
will be bad with that but you can't just
like throw out the whole thing
before we get to by the way if people
are interested in this technology aspect
neil postman has a book technopoly which
is really interesting and i can strongly
recommend to people before we get back
to splinterlands a little bit
with crypto and also now with nfts i get
a lot of emails and see youtube comments
about the environmental impact with
bitcoin the mining piece and electrical
electricity usage is sort of well known
can you talk a little bit about that as
a more general gripe with crypto and
nfts
yeah you know the
i'm not an expert at mining i i
certainly read on both sides of just how
much energy consumption has involved and
then where those sources are i mean even
if you had a lot of like energy
consumption if it was coming from like
geothermal wells or volcanoes or other
other kinds of elements it's not adding
any difference to the way that things
operate but it might look scary so i i
worry about those numbers and i'm not
sure that i have a good picture but a
lot of a lot of that the a lot of that
energy consumption is really around
proof of work and specifically bitcoin
when you get into proof of stake
delegated proof of stake and other
consensus models you know now the
hardcore bitcoin community doesn't like
it because it's not proof of work but
now you get into other models that
aren't necessarily resource intensive at
all um and in fact could be you know
fractions and fractions of a kilowatt to
make like a single nft or move something
it's like you know basically
basically so far in the noise that
you're like you know i run a computer
and at my house and if i leave my
screens on long enough you know that's
taking more energy than like a million
different transactions going through for
at least the splinterlands tech so you
know again this stuff blockchain is not
one blockchain there's not one chain in
this world there's like 2 000 now some
of them are going to be energy intensive
others are not so it you know you gotta
you got to choose your chain with your
value system and say you know what i
really value is environmental impact and
i want my kilowatt usage to be as low as
possible and then you find the chain
that mimics that and other people might
want it to be as expensive as possible
meaning the nfts some people might want
the community to be as big as possible
you know you got to vote with your own
conscious and your own ability or or
even if you if you feel like the the
market is missing something come
participate and build the most
environmentally friendly technology that
you can
you know there there are different ways
that you can interact but just blanketly
saying none of this is helpful i mean to
me you look at like every single you
know nft on this planet is like a
fraction of one day of war in this world
so like you know when you put this stuff
into perspective there's a lot of fake
or like frustrating outrage about nfts
where i would be like well maybe if we
stop bombing countries for another day
or something like that would take care
of every single nft issuance for like
the next 20 years well you also don't
even have to make that comparison i mean
i think the other thing is and again i'm
not like a cheerleader or a detractor
i'm just seeing this as these are tools
that can be used as you say in very
different ways
the sort of um
legacy
cash and banking world
also has a massive footprint i mean when
you consider
all the heavy
uh inefficient um armored car carriers
driving all around every city in the
world literally just moving cash around
when you consider that you know all
these american tourists that go all over
europe exchanging dollars for euros all
those dollars or at least at one point
part of those dollars are physically
then flown back to the united states to
be redeposited here and the carbon
footprint of that a lot of times i feel
like people are comparing everything to
the idea of zero when we already aren't
at zero with with other systems that
exist as well
yeah
yeah i think that's a fair thing to say
we you should compare against what's
actually in existence and what's
actually in existence is producing a lot
of war
poverty and this giant surveillance
system and this nft
approach to solving things in a
different way doesn't automatically
solve everything but there are elements
here that if we collectively use them
wisely and support businesses that make
sense that we can actually have nice
things and have a cleaner environment
and have ownership of digital assets um
and do that in such a way that this
stuff
is not hurting us or our environment but
reducing the strain that already exists
so with splinter lands i mean what
what's what's the vision what's the idea
here in terms of where you are and where
you want to go
so
one of the first frustrations was that
you know if you go and buy a video game
and you spend you know a month or two
playing it and then you're done you walk
away and you have nothing and you have
spent hours and hours your money is
wasted and that that company that sold
you that software is richer but there's
no benefit to the user and what we like
more of like those old trading card
games where you know magic and pokemon
and um there you would actually have a
card or an asset so you know you could
trade that at the schoolyard or trade
that somewhere but once you have that
asset you know it's it's not like going
to the movies anymore you know you go to
the movies you spend your 20 bucks you
get your entertainment and then you're
done uh and we all sort of recognize
that you know a little bit of that is
fine but you know like in in the trading
card world what's nice is that you own
these things so if you if you like take
your hundred dollar bill and you buy
cards i don't think of that as like
spending money i know that people do but
you know i don't really spend money on a
car you know you buy a car but it's not
spent spen has that like ephemeral taste
to the word where the money is just gone
so again you're like buying assets and
in this case um we can build uh
cryptocurrencies that we award to users
so that when they play this game they
can earn
and that's that's a fascinating change
of pace for this world normally you
think how much can i extract money from
this gamer not how much can i facilitate
them earning and now through things like
playing video games and especially
during things like this pandemic where
like whole countries can be on lockdown
and you can't get to work you can't do
things you know maybe maybe this is
actual wage for some people but so it's
oftentimes just like a supplemental wage
um and so you're earning by playing
and and i think that can help change the
world because now now you're like
playing with other people there's
commerce you're trading cards and i
think just that you know it's not just
our game but i think cryptocurrency
enables a lot of this kind of
cross-border commerce and that as we get
more and more interconnected
i think it's more and more likely that
we'll continue to have peaceful
interactions rather than violent
interactions as whole swaths of
communities get financially intertwined
and just to give people to be really
specific rather than vague the play to
earn model in splinterland works how in
other words how does the play
generate that value so there's there's a
reward pool where people are able to
earn tokens and there's a set amount of
tokens that go out each day and the
players are competing over them
a rough formula is as you rank up by
winning matches if you double your rank
you can octuple your rewards that's not
exact but that's a rough system of how
we built that and it provides a lot of
incentive to go get a high quality deck
to put in a bunch of time and play this
game and um to like battle your way into
into glory and riches you know because
there's so much money that players can
earn just by playing the game uh there's
there's actually reason to own these
assets and rent them to others so i have
i have players that will buy digital
assets not with the intent to play but
to rent out to other players and so now
across this entire economic spectrum
from the smallest minnow to the biggest
whale you know we have people that are
yeah i had i had folks send me a picture
of a bed and they said hey aggie this
game has changed my life i'm no longer
sleeping on the floor thanks so much
here's this beautiful bed and i've also
had people that have sent me pictures of
homes or cars and and all along the way
they're saying things like this game has
changed my life thanks so much and on
the upper end they usually end it with
please write tax software so that we can
figure out what to do with all these
earnings and so you know and that's
that's the dream to me the dream is not
you know just make it so that whales are
are bigger whales and it's not you can't
we're not going to run a game just by
like distributing money to the poor
there's got to be this entire ecosystem
that allows all participants that are uh
that are engaged in the game to do
better and i think i think that's where
we're at with splinter lands you can
learn more about splinterlands at
splinterlands.com we've been speaking
with the ceo jesse agro-dreich jesse
always appreciate your time and insights
and great to see you yeah it's good good
to be back thank you david and uh glad
to see your your channels are growing
and you're doing well